the Jersey Shore has announced a new
season but who needs Snooki Mike and
Pauly when we've got Donald Chuck and
Nancy we will analyze our wonderfully
entertaining reality TV reality then
alley Stuckey Alicia crass and Jacob
Airy joined the panel of deplorable z'
to discuss new discoveries about the
tomb of Jesus spoiler alert is empty why
Millennials say I feel instead of I
think it's probably because they feel
and they don't think and the latest in
Democrat sex scandals I'm Michael
Knowles and this is the Michael Noel's
show
[Music]
I am so excited that the Jersey Shore is
back I am as excited as anybody else is
in case you have never experienced this
wonderful show seems to think that my
hair is gonna fall off and go onto the
ice cream it's hair ain't moving my dude
150 miles an hour on the highway on a
street bike doesn't move what makes you
think it's gonna move in a gelato shop I
love that show so much I loved it in
college I I used to go to the Jersey
Shore all the time when I was a kid I
would go to Wildwood with my family I
one time I was at what a Seaside Heights
also known as sleaze side Heights
visiting a buddy in college and we saw
we went to the house while they were
filming we saw a massive crowd down
below because the situation was smoking
a cigarette on the balcony I actually
don't ask me why I know this I was
conceived at the Jersey Shore Wildwood
on the 4th of July of all times I again
please I sort of wish I didn't know that
so anyway I love the show
but do we need it anymore do we actually
need reality television I don't know man
because we have the swampy sure we have
the reality TV of one President Donald
Trump and the Washington DC that is
revolving around him plus we have a
great cast of characters that he's given
us we it's extremely entertaining and
this should not be surprising at all
because it really does politics in 2017
more so than it did previously
more so than we've ever seen in the past
it resembles reality TV because we made
the king of reality television president
this guy had a reality TV show one of
the defining reality TV shows on network
television for 14 years it was about him
it starred him it was about his life and
his
company it was a great basically a game
show so we had like these constant
celebrities and new characters who came
by this is the culture I noticed all of
the people who for years and years have
sat at Heritage Foundation lunches and
have written in all of the elite
publications on the right they've called
for a culture warrior in the White House
we have to wage the culture wars
everything else is just accounting and
they they seem to have had a vision of
what that culture warrior would look
like and it didn't look like Donald
Trump so now that he is waging the
cultural wars they hate it and they're
saying it's uncouth and they're running
away from him and their to their home is
rating with their friends on the left
and at the New York Times and and in
left-wing outlets and they're saying oh
yes ISM it's so awful
I don't like that guy he says strange
words but look I'm for is elite elite
culture as much as the next guy it
actually occurred to me while I was
writing this I was listening to abjure
at AB joven ma Pais it's if you listen
to chanting or anything on unspotted I
you'll see these ridiculous songs that
come out of Provencal poetry but guess
what folks Provencal poetry is not the
culture that we live in it's a nice
culture if you you know if you want to
read old books and read old poetry and
and that sort of thing I'm all for it I
like the Opera I like going to plays but
that isn't the actual culture and if we
have rich uncle Pennybags become the
nominee of the Republican Party and wear
a monocle and talk about how great Don
Giovanni is or how he only listens to
Bach that doesn't engage in the culture
he might be a well formed fella but that
isn't the culture that the American
people pay attention to so the NFL that
is the culture reality television that
is the culture and we now have a guy
who's constantly talking about the NFL
who's talking about celebrities
who's waging the war where it exists now
we have these two characters we have
Chuck and Nancy but that doesn't take
into account my favorite character which
is Pocahontas we'll get to Pocahontas in
a little here's what here's what Chuck
and Nancy wrote this morning Donald
Trump tweeted quote meeting with Chuck
and Nancy today about keeping government
open and working problem is they want
illegal immigrants flooding into our
country unchecked or weak on crime
want to substantially raise taxes I
don't see a deal don't you after all you
know this is poetic diction been talked
about an excellent book by owen Barfield
poetic diction on his show the other day
this is poetic diction it offers us so
much in just what three sentences he
gives us the characters he gives us the
protagonists that's Donald Trump this is
what I want to do I want to keep our
country open I want to keep the
government working then he gives us the
antagonists that's Chuck and Nancy he
doesn't say senators Schumer and
congresswoman Pelosi leader Pelosi he
says it even puts it in quotes Chuck and
Nancy you know them they come through
your TV every night you know them
they're like a sitcom character they're
like a reality television character he
then presents himself not only as the
reasonable guy but he's the innocent guy
he it's almost laughable it is laughable
this tweet because he's saying look this
is what I want I just want these good
things for the country and so I'm gonna
meet with them today you know the only
trouble is the only thing I suspect this
might not go very well because they're
they're anti-american monsters who want
to destroy your country for you so I
don't think there will be a deal but
maybe there will be right he presents
himself as this perfectly innocent
player and he's forcing them into a
corner they can't come to the meeting
now he's just said that they want to
flood this country with criminals and
illegal immigrants that they want to
raise your taxes and destroy your
country so he doesn't see a deal but hey
you know maybe maybe it'll work out they
can't possibly come so if they don't
come then it just underscores the
narrative he wants to work together he
wants to reach across the aisle he wants
to do positive work for the country but
these obstructionists among Democrats
will not do it and and not only that but
they're humorless that's the other
accusation that he's he's constantly
implicitly leveling against them and so
what happened they cancelled the meeting
of course they had to and then Sarah
Huckabee Sanders sends out a press
release and says the president's
invitation to the Democrat leaders still
stands and he encourages them to put
aside their pettiness stop the political
grandstanding show up and get to work
these issues are too important it's
exactly the it was ever thus the minute
he wrote this tweet and now he looks
like the adult which is crazy
he's written this this
the sort of statement from the president
that we've never seen before he's
written this and then ironically he's
the one who ends up looking like an
adult you know this is no surprise this
should come as no surprise to us but
many people on the left and the right
are constantly scratching their heads
are saying what is he doing how could he
be doing this if only he did something
different then it would all work out
great you know you've got to give this
guy a little bit of credit he has been
manipulating people to do what he wants
them to do for decades but he's done it
explicitly on television for 15 years
this was his job was to take regular
people not with a script not with
characters that he's written regular
people that he's met in life and get
them to do what he wants them to do to
create entertainment on television that
is that was truly his job for 15 years
so this brings us to our next character
my favorite one that would be Pocahontas
here's Trump yesterday at an event
honoring the Navajo code talkers for the
country so that was the ultimate
statement from general Kelly the
importance and I just want to thank you
because you have very very special
people you were here long before any of
us were here although we have a
representative in Congress who they say
was here a long time ago they call her a
Pocahontas but you know what I like you
because you are special you are special
people you are really incredible people
and from the heart from the absolute
heart we appreciate what you've done how
you've done it the bravery that you
display and the love that you have for
your country Tom I would say that's as
as good as it gets that is as good as it
gets
it was perfectly executed those guys
don't look too offended for those of you
who aren't watching because you haven't
subscribed go over and subscribe but if
you're just listening when he says
Pocahontas they're smiling a little
they're laughing a little it's not
they're not taking a back and saying how
awful this is and by the way Pocahontas
wasn't Navajo Pocahontas wasn't Cherokee
as is Elizabeth Warren
lying said that she was but he's mocking
her he's mocking her in this moment why
because it's a little aside he's
honoring these guys in an event he's
obviously heaping praise on them and
then he gets his little joke in there
why because why is he mocking Elizabeth
Warren Elizabeth Warren deserves to be
mocked Elizabeth Warren pretended to be
a Native American Indian she is as white
as can be I am farce worthier than
Elizabeth Warren ever ever could
possibly be even you know during this
summer in the Sun and Elizabeth Warren
didn't just say that she did she was a
Native American Indian on job
applications she didn't just talk about
it in her life she submitted a recipe to
a cookbook called powwow Chow what it
doesn't get much more egregious than
that she is prostituting her fake
ancestry clearly for a career benefit
and but Donald Trump is the one who's
offensive by making this joke and
pointing it out but by the way this
event would not have been covered by the
press had he not made that remark he
knows that that's why he made the remark
we wouldn't have seen wall-to-wall
coverage of the Navajo code talkers
honor summit had he not made this line
so like catnip the press can't resist
and once again what are we talking about
we're not talking about Bob Mulder we're
not talking about Russia we're talking
about how Elizabeth Warren is a liar and
there's a clearly white woman pretended
to be a Native American to further her
career so how did Warren respond I think
you guessed it it is deeply unfortunate
that the President of the United States
cannot even make it through a ceremony
honoring these heroes without having to
throw out a racial slur look Donald
Trump does this over and over thinking
somehow he's going to shut me up with it
it hadn't worked in the past it is not
going to work in the future it's a
racial slur didn't you know that
Pocahontas is a racial slur did you know
that marshal I don't know in my PC
training there are a lot of slurs that I
was told not to say Pocahontas wasn't
one of them
because Pocahontas was a Native American
Indian from the Northeast of America and
also a Disney cartoon so it's not a
racial slur and Ann Coulter once gave me
tremendous advice the first time I met
her when I was in college we were
talking about how all the crazies at
college would call you racist for saying
that we ought to have lower taxes and
less government in our lives and she
said you know Michael when a liberal
called you a racist you know you've won
the argument and that's true she has no
argument here
she can't answer for her fraud for her
decades of fraud so what she has to do
she looks ridiculous in every sense of
that word to kink that she is like
Pocahontas which she claimed to be is
ridiculous it makes you laugh it makes
you laugh at her but she can't laugh she
is humorless that's what it reminds me
of that meme that was going around of
Sandra Fluke who has her arms crossed
she was that Democrat contrivance who
took the sacramental view of birth
control she was a head her arms crossed
and frowning and it said that's not
funny that's what elizabeth warren looks
like she seems like a scold she seems
humorless how did that work for Hillary
Clinton he's forced her into this corner
to make her deeply unlikable not that
I'm saying she wasn't unlikable before
but Donald Trump is making her look even
more unlikable and by the way she says
that he's doing this to shut her up
no he isn't he's doing it to get her on
TV and to make her look as humorless as
she is he isn't shutting her up at all
it isn't just shut her up
it's to make her look ridiculous which
she is you see this played out to
yesterday there was that drama at the
CFPB
speaking of Elizabeth Warren the board
the Consumer Financial so called
Protection Bureau that Elizabeth Warren
promoted and helped to create even
before she was a member of the Senate
the drama that happened at the CFPB is
that the director resigned he named his
deputy a woman named Leanne for English
to take over but he has no authority to
do that the president can name the head
of his executive agencies so instead of
formally nominating somebody and taking
care of this in paperwork basically what
Donald Trump was was he named an interim
director Mick Mulvaney his budget
director to walk down there with a bag
of Dunkin Donuts and take over the the
office why did he do it this way he
could have handled this much more
quietly
why did he have to send down a person
well if he had found some boring
bureaucratic solution on paper to do
this then it might have taken care of
this particular problem but it wouldn't
have pointed out that this issue of the
CFPB and all of these godless headless
native agencies is not a boring
bureaucratic problem I had the privilege
of meeting Antonin Scalia we asked him
what the greatest threat to Liberty was
in the United States
he said it's these agencies these
executive agencies who have no
accountability certainly to Congress and
in this case apparently not to the
president so he sent down a person Mick
Mulvaney an outspoken critic of this
agency to have human drama two heads two
directors of the agency duking it out
total catnip for the press and we get to
see the this issue brought into stark
relief does a legitimately elected
president sent there by the American
people does he have the right to run his
own executive agencies or is some
bureaucrat holdover who thinks that she
knows better how to run your life than
you do who thinks she knows better had
to run your government than you do is
she the one who should do it
it's a beautiful human drama it's people
who represent different groups and you
know that there was a commentator I
can't remember I couldn't find his name
today there was a commentator in 2016
who predicted the Trump would win
because we want to keep watching the
show we can't turn off this reality TV
show we want to see season two America
just wouldn't be able to help itself a
lot of people on on the left and the
right are saying Trump is doing horrible
and he should abandon Twitter or Trump
is doing fine but he should abandon
Twitter and Twitter as the key humor is
the key this isn't just bread and
circuses by the way we're seeing a lot
of great stuff happen in the federal
government we're seeing massive
deregulation an annual 13,000
regulations passed and Platt passed
every single year by the federal
government for the last 20 years this
year zero net new regulations massive
deregulation at the EPA Scott Pruett has
been doing an excellent job
judge Gorsuch and a supremely good
nominee and now Supreme Court justice a
ton of other judges have been nominated
some have been confirmed you know there
the humor has been really a great way to
accomplish political goals and rather
than encouraging Trump to abandon all of
that cough FA we should encourage him to
keep it up this has been an immense help
to him and the show must go on folks we
don't want to turn this show off so to
continue to discuss reality television
have to bring on our excellent panel of
deplorable 'z but before we do and we
have a great panel today we have Allie
Stuckey we have Alicia crass The Daily
wires own we have Jacob Airy aren't two
out of three ain't bad but before we do
that we have to make a little money
folks we have to tell you about a great
a great help to your holiday season
winter is coming and one way to keep the
lights on here and also to keep the
lights on in your head and actually
learn something and be able to digest a
lot of the information and commentary
that you want to digest is this great
app called texture so texture is a way I
read magazines
I used to subscribe to all the print
magazines but that's very expensive and
they just clutter up your coffee table
and it's it's kind of hard to work
through instead there's this great app
which is called texture whether you're
looking for dependable political
reporting high-quality storytelling
culture entertainment all of the above
you don't only have to listen to this
podcast you should probably be reading
magazines as well they deliver it all
with beautiful writing
excellent prose prose that you don't
always find on just the news websites
that we're all constantly consuming and
you can get it all in one place it gives
you access texture to unlimited access
to over 200 premium magazines
it has leading titles time the Atlantic
the New York or Vanity Fair Wired the
National Review right now you can try
that app for free it's especially good
in the holiday season I love nothing
more than to cuddle up next to my
Christmas tree with those gigantic
incandescent bulbs you know the ones
that almost set your tree on fire and it
just feels warm it feels like you're
you're snuggled up and just read I do it
every night and the texture is a really
great way to do it these if you
subscribe to all of these magazines
would cost you a ton of money but right
now imagine having it all anywhere
anytime just right on your mobile device
if you want to start your free trial
which I recommend go to texture dot-com
slash Knowles that's KN o wles just like
Beyonce texture comm slash Knowles if
you choose to continue podcast listeners
will get the whole thing for how much
how much would you pay for this Marshall
that's a lot I mean you don't read but
if you read you know you'd have to
subscribe what is it every month it's 5
to 15 bucks for any magazine
if you want to get unlimited magazines
what would that be a million dollars a
jillion dollars no siree Bob $9.99 a
month that this is a really good deal
and especially it's a great deal to try
it for free which you should all do
right now that's 30% even off of
textures listed price great gift options
available for that loved one in your
life as holiday season texture calm /
Knowles to start your free trial today
that's what is it Marshall you got it
you got it it's a see he's learning we
will get them a trial Marshall will read
will discuss our reading together go do
it and let me know what you think of it
because I mean I think it's really
excellent all right let's get into our
we have a lot of excellent topics to
discuss today let's begin with ally ally
will anybody watch the New Jersey Shore
where his politics made a reality TV
completely irrelevant oh I don't know
politics making Jersey Shore irrelevant
I think it was probably already like
that much before Donald Trump seems like
you might be an expert you're much
higher brow than me other much more
sophisticated reality shows like The
Bachelor and the Bachelorette that you
know things like Jersey Shore they're
just beneath me what can I say that
makes perfect sense on this reality TV
show that we have in front of us the
Trump show the swampy shore Alysha which
is racist because Elizabeth Warren says
calling her Pocahontas is racist what is
more racist to call Elizabeth Warren a
white woman who isn't Native American
Pocahontas were for Elizabeth Warren to
pretend to be a Native American Indian
and write a recipe for a book called
powwow Chow yeah that was a crab recipe
hailing from Oklahoma its southeastern
Oklahoma specifically there are no crabs
there we do have crawdads though those
mud bugs are awake grosser than crab
and she also hailing from Oklahoma I
guess she needs to apologize where she
was raised because it's you know stands
for land of the red people it's like
ridiculous
it's like legitimately Pocahontas was
somebody's name and I do I like it was
cringe-worthy yesterday wind Trump said
this in front of these American heroes
that are probably pushing 100 let's be
honest but it's it's Trump like I mean
that's that's just him and the CNN and
MSNBC wall-to-wall coverage about how he
was racist is just it's beyond it is
beyond and those guys I mean you point
out they are probably like a hundred
years old at this point they seem to get
a kind of a kick out of it they smiles
they didn't it was wrong come on it was
awkward smile oh well you know that's
the thing I notice about this
administration is it's always awkward
smiles because you can't predict any of
this stuff do you remember 2012 when
Clint Eastwood came to the RNC and he
talked to an empty chair and he just
gave a ad-libbed of speech to an empty
chair and a lot of people who was very
cringy we didn't know what to do
John Stewart said he loved it John
Stewart said he loved it because it was
unscripted it wasn't the usual glossed
over scripted political convention we
see it was a little awkward and a little
weird and you just don't know it to me
maybe it's like a car wreck but you
can't help but watch it Jacob the Jersey
Shore you might not have watched it I
certainly did and I believe it was Vinny
on the Jersey Shore said that things
were gonna get filthy creepy and weird
that's how it defines itself certainly
politics these days is filthy creepy and
weird what with all of the sex scandals
and and whatnot is there any way to add
a little dignity to either our
television our popular culture and our
politics or are we just on a straight
train to decadence I think we're on a
straight train to decadence it's fine I
think I'm sorry to be a killjoy here but
I just I don't think the train ride is
going to get any smoother it's gonna be
bumpy all the way and by the way Bullock
crawdads are way better than crabs but
anyway that's neither here nor there dad
just
that statement is a nice way to typify
how everything you say it like the
opposite is true we shouldn't trust any
of your opinion I grew up caged and I
grew up on crawdads but this things are
so gross anyway well yeah well the
peeling of them is gross but you know
once you actually get them in New
England elitist by the way this is how I
feel about Trump the peeling of it is
gross the kind of watching it the first
time even the voting I know but then
once you're in there oh man it's so
delicious that khofifah is great okay we
have a lot more to talk about but if you
don't subscribe to The Daily wire com I
can't help you pal I guess you can
listen to it on iTunes or something but
if you want to watch the rest of this
show and help us keep the lights on we
really appreciate it to all of our
current subscribers it really helps us
out do that right now you go to daily
wire.com what do you get you get no ads
on the website that's pretty big there
are so many ads on every website these
days that's a big deal you get me get
the under Clavin show you get the Ben
Shapiro show yeah yeah I get it
guys Christmas season is coming up it's
the holidays it's the holiday season you
could get your very own leftist tears
tumblr now I would say this makes a
great stocking stuffer but that's not
true would make a great main gift made
only gift to any of your loved ones but
I know you're not going to give it to
anybody you're gonna keep it for
yourself as you should this season the
tears are pouring that that excellent
vintage that Native American powwow
vintage of Elizabeth Warren's Pocahontas
tears that is filling up vessels left
and right you are going to need this
leftist yours tumbler otherwise you're
gonna drown in those tears there they
can be hot they can be cold there always
salty and delicious so go over to daily
wire calm right now we'll be right back
[Music]
[Music]
all right enough reality TV there is
some good news just in time for
Christmas
see what I did there scientific tests
have offered new evidence that the
Church of the Holy Sepulcher where Jesus
is believed to have been buried though
not for very long does in fact date back
to the Roman Empire to at least the time
of Constantine
now previous experiments only dated it
to around 1,000 years old but now we
know it goes back to at least the time
when Constantine started to renovate the
place and make it a nice temple and nice
what would eventually become a church
Alicia
everybody I noticed on today's panel is
Christian at least should do scientific
core operations such as this one do they
do anything to augment your faith or do
you draw some sort of hard line between
your faith and other things you know
about the world between theology and
things in natural science I'm really
sleep-deprived today so of course you
went to me I gotta say in layman's terms
no I mean I think I kind of read
articles like this and I'm like that's
cool but there's an aspect of like faith
and and like you don't have to believe
to see actually I think that was
something that like Jesus said you know
my confirmation yeah okay good for you
for not you know like why are you
doubting and so I think that it is
something that's cool I'm somebody that
has never been to the Holy Land would
love to visit the Holy Lands I've heard
it's like a life-changing moment and
experience I've lots of friends and
family that have done it but I don't
think that I don't need to see like oh
is this exactly where the manger was is
this exactly the hill that Jesus died on
is this exactly the tomb that he was
laid in for three days in order for my
faith to be solidified because it's
called faith for a reason that's true
and he makes that point you know it's
very nice to see and then believe but
blessed are those who have not seen and
yet believed and yet as you say I also
haven't been to Israel but everyone who
goes is just stunned and bowled over by
it and goes back many times make makes
the pilgrimage so there is something
about Christianity that is unique unlike
other world religions Christianity is
founded on fact
rather than philosophy it begins it
doesn't begin with some poetry or some
philosophy it begins with a journalistic
account of a guy who lived in a place at
a time who who is performing miracles
who is doing things in which the
physical and the metaphysical unites so
Ali that unique foundation of
Christianity as as journalism basically
does that do anything to shape your
political views or your your views of
the rest of the world I think so you
think that all faiths some degree or all
of the major religions to some degree
field that they are founded in fact and
be they usually are found up in some
fact Mohammed was someone who really
existed although I think the unique
thing about Christianity was not the
fact that it started I guess
journalistically but just that it's
different in any other faith in our
philosophy of what we believe every
other faith tells you how to get to God
so if God is on the top of the hill it
tells you all of the ways that you have
to climb up the hill in order to get
yeah um
Christianity is different and that Jesus
came down the hill to lie so you didn't
have to do anything to get to God I
think that's the difference and that's
really what keeps my baby is the offer
of reconciliation through no nothing of
our own and I think that's really what
makes me a friends hey buddy and that
bad luck well maybe we'll get we'll get
rid of superstition for Christmas I
don't know what the pastor's kid thinks
though well I want to get to that but on
this point of Muhammad it is worth
noting yeah he's a guy who lived in time
Moses lived in time in a place Abraham
but it's only in Christ that we see a
guy who's saying I am God even Mohammed
doesn't go that far because of course
Mohammed founded his religion after
spending weeks with a heretical
Christian monk over in Syria so the that
uniting it it reminds me I was reading
this book last month called symbolism
and belief by Edwin Bevan that CS Lewis
recommends and he talks about how values
values and these ethereal ideas for our
lives it's very easy to intellectualize
them and just think of them as up here
but really they're they're put into
bodies they
really matter when humans do something
with them right we have to use them in
space and time the book in the New
Testament isn't called the ideas of the
Apostles it's called the Acts of the
Apostles it's the life of Jesus that we
see it's not just like the heretical
Gospel of Thomas it's not just random
sayings of his we follow biographies
through his life and so that that does
shape my view of politics and it makes
it less rationalist makes it less just
about sitting back and saying oh yes
this would be good but I'm standing for
something you know the rationalist
always stands for something
but he won't walk he won't move you
won't do things Jacob does it does it
affect your politics
Oh Esther's kid oh master's son yeah
absolutely and in fact I remember when I
was far away from my faith I went
through a period there in my college
years where I kind of backed away from
my faith I was questioning God and
that's when I became a liberal that's
when I started to experiment with
leftism was I was I was away from my
faith but then as soon as I rediscovered
my faith I guess you could say that's
when I went oh you know what children
are babies in the womb are children they
are alive they do have they do have a
purpose so yes definitely my certainly
my faith in Jesus Christ has affected
how I see the how I see the world as far
as politics and just even in the way I
live my life we all experiment with
weird stuff in college there's a time
and a place for everything in that place
is college so speaking of college there
is an excellent professor a law
professor at Faulkner University named
Adam McLean who insists that any student
who uses the phrase I feel instead of I
think must cluck like a chicken and if
they use isms you know those is this is
Amman that ISM or if they use vague
trendy words like fair diversity etc
they must immediately stop and explain
what they think I noticed this in
college too for comment we turn to every
millennial okay like right now for
example the Hayden's
need to come to America but some people
are all what about the strain on our
resources and it's like when I had this
garden party for my father's birthday
right that is so profound that really
changed the way I think about
you know like Alicia yeah oh you might
have noticed this too
the language has changed now people
don't say I think we're I believe all
the time it's all bet but they'll you
know I feel like it would be better if
we do this I feel like this was kind of
interesting
why the change why do Millennials only
use the phrase I feel I blame the public
education system I also think that
clucking like a chicken is not
punishment enough because let's be
honest drunk people do the chicken dance
at weddings all across America yeah your
cameras out of my apartment oh you just
do them in your apartment Wow is like
prepping a dance for your wedding time
entails in school but I I think that it
is definitely something to do with what
we see on TV what we what our generation
has read in media what we you know
romantic comedies even that like women
are raised from seeing from the 80s and
Beyond not that romantic comedies aren't
amazing but it does kind of teach this
and reinforce this belief that
everything is about feeling versus facts
like our buddy Ben says yeah for this
Amanda she's just somewhere I think it
might be a pinch tweet somewhere and and
I think that that is really continued
over and it's something that you see
continually in the education system I
mean I'm looking at schools right now
for my four-year-old and every every
single tour the two questions that are
given the most time is the diversity
question and what about the feelings of
the students and I'm like no not what
about the feelings of the students what
are you gonna do to get my kid into
Harvard you know a professor of mine in
college had a theory on all of this he
this guy Charles Hill he's a lifelong
diplomat ambassador and his his idea was
that over time students have become much
more afraid to make any statements of
fact they're they're too afraid because
they think that the facts can be
offensive so you used to say the sky is
blue and then you could say well I I
think the sky is blue you know that's
just my opinion and we still I believe
the sky is blue because belief is a
little a little more wish washy and then
ultimately again I feel like the sky's
blue even the word like which we make
fun of the valley girl well isn't it
like this and that even though we're
like is distancing yourself it's it's a
simile you're not saying the thing is
what it is you're saying it's like
something else
and that gives you a lot of wiggle room
now Ali you are a conservative
millennial I've read somewhere is it
that Millennials are afraid of making
statements of fact they seem hysterical
in in many ways what what is going on
here with the relationship of
Millennials to objective truth I do
think it's like you and you have both
noted this kind of popularization of
subjectivity and kind of shame about
being objective and it's not just
objectivity but we're so afraid of being
judgemental the worst thing you can be
after being a racist and a bigoted a
homophobe is being judgmental so you see
that anything is right or wrong
especially if you're on the right um
that you're not only a big but you are
you know you're morally wrong and so I
think it is in an effort to avoid being
judgmental or being called a bigot or
what-have-you and people start with I
feel like or I think it's also something
that you learn in like conflict
resolution or if you go to like
premarital counseling they always tell
you to start with I feel because it
takes the responsibility off of the
person that you're talking to it's like
I feel like you're being really rude I
mean that's just my feeling but I feel
like it um so I think that's kind of
what we're going for we're so afraid of
conflict we're so afraid of objectivity
we're so afraid of being called a bigot
or judgmental then if we're just
starting with our own feelings you can't
get mad at me for that it's kind of like
so you know offense and you're actually
being really great people only say that
when they're being extremely offensive
you know is it well no offense don't
whatever you're gonna say don't say
we've got to bless your heart I think
it's also because people don't
understand what an opinion is anymore we
learn this incorrectly in schools that
people think in an opinion is a
preference so they think you know if I
could say the sky is blue that's a fact
I can say I think the sky is blue that's
an opinion but it's a true opinion now
if I say I like the blue sky or the blue
sky sky pleases me I guess that's a
preference I prefer cheese sandwiches to
ham sandwiches that's a preference but
just say I think and then a statement of
fact that's an opinion but an opinion
states
act now Jacob this is a very frustrating
issue when you talk to Millennials about
this they want conflict resolution just
as Ali has said but sometimes you need
to push you need to push arguments to
their extreme to actually get to an
answer
to actually see the world clearly what
is to blame for this why are Millennials
so afraid of conflict is it is it the
helicopter parenting is hit the
anti-bullying campaigns why are we so
afraid of getting Mitte and gritty in
arguments with people I think it has to
do with a pop culture honestly I mean
even if you grew up in the 90s like I
did and you had the greatest version of
the Disney Channel original series you
use every problem is solved in 20
minutes or less right and so whenever a
problem goes beyond that 20 minute mark
you're like where's I need a commercial
break right now
so I think that it has to do with I just
want to resolve this quickly or it gets
uncomfortable and just like and also has
something to do with a tally said being
judgmental we don't want to come off as
judgmental even if we know we're right
so when we say oh a bortion is murder
and then a leftist says well that's
judgmental you're judging someone and
like well I'm judging whether the fact
that this person has a life or not and
if that life has intrinsic value and I
think my judgment is correct and we just
need a Millennials need to not be afraid
especially conservative Millennials need
to not be afraid to stand up and say
look this might not be solved in 20
minutes or less we're just gonna have to
work it out and get all the facts
it is totally an example of politics
following culture of the culture being
so insidious in ways we can't recognize
I hadn't even considered that and on the
judge eNOS they don't be judgy don't be
judgmental you hear this phrase
sometimes now which is don't you um
don't ya don't say that the thing I like
is disgusting or something and the
logical conclusion of this is what
happened in the 20th century is a major
movement among leftist intellectuals to
normalize pedophilia and now obviously
this is in the air with they say that
Roy Moore I guess that wasn't pedophilia
that was probably close to benefit you
know it's a fee Buffy Leah's post
pubescent girls but nevertheless girls
were too young to be having sex with and
you're picking them up there was this
movement to normalize all of that and we
should yuck that YUM if somebody finds
that yummy let's yakit man we can't we
can't have too much of that and speaking
of sex in true reality TV form we have
to close on that the latest in Democrat
sex scandals Bernie Sanders you will
recall years ago claimed that women
fantasize about gang rape another woman
has accused democrat Rep John Conyers of
sexual harassment Democrat Rep Al Green
we've learned once threatened to sue a
staffer that he had had sex with because
she threatened to go public and I am by
the way I'm not making any accusations
lawyers who are watching this no
accusations are being made however Keith
Olbermann is suddenly unexpectedly and
inexplicably retiring from political
media in all forms one wonders how long
before the accusations start rolling in
hmm I don't know I'll begin with the man
on this panel and then I can be educated
by the ladies on this panel
Jacob is any man ever going to be able
to hold political office again men are
filthy dogs
that's almost universally true how our
men forget how our men going to hold
office anymore why would they even run
when all of their bizarre sexual
experiences are gonna come back finally
invite them well I think that yes well
this is we have to be careful what is
part of the hysteria and what is
actually credible allegations and so as
far as as far as will men run again I
think so the I think we'll see more of
the pence roll being adopted you know
I'm gonna I'm gonna go visit this with
this female staffer or I'm gonna meet
with this female colleague but I'm gonna
always have a chaperone but people
aren't going but people are gonna still
say the pinch roll is uncool because it
just sounds so uncool you know but I
honestly think that we'll see this being
implemented more and as far as Keith
Olbermann goes I think I'm expecting to
hear him joining the Young Turks or RT
that's that's my prediction I could be
wrong about that but that's you know
what happened with Jesse Ventura and I
expect that's gonna happen with Keith
Olbermann well fair enough because he
said he would retire from political
commentary in all forms but the Young
Turks is just incoherent babbling and
exactly at ease
and Artie is Russian propaganda and
Robert Z is Russian propaganda Alicia
this is definitely the pendulum is
swinging we're quite in the opposite
direction that we were in the 1990s yeah
is that going to itself prompted
backlash where is this going to settle
is this going to settle that any
politician who's ever had an
extramarital affair can't hold office
you know like every single politician
ever on the face of the earth maybe
other than Mike Pence or is this going
to settle somewhere else or Mitt Romney
I mean for the bus I really think he was
a good guy and when we wanted to elect a
good guy versus you know Barack Obama
people are like no he was too big
they're full of women what what is that
that's true he was too good I do find it
kind of fascinating how I have
conversations with liberal friends and
now they're coming to the side of oh
yeah even though they won't call it
morality kind of things our rules and
regulations they are now coming to the
side of things like the pence roll
seemed cool I mean look at all the
praise that David Schwimmer got when he
conducted that interview with the
chaperone everybody was during the
hashtag me too movement was like oh my
god he's such a gentleman that's so
amazing Mike Pence and David French do
it and it's oh my god monstro anti-women
they're monsters and I find it really
weird this convergence of right and left
or moral and you know people that tend
to be non-religious and you know more
immoral now saying that these
old-fashioned rules can apply to 2017
that's the wonder about the new
Victorian era Ali
almost one in five married couples met
at work according to some study that I
don't know it's somewhere all those
studies are probably nonsense but they
say you know we've seen this before a
lot of people who are married meet at
work possibly up to 20% so now that
we're in this new era where the pendulum
is so flown the other way will that lead
to a neo Victorianism where we can no
longer make any comments about our
co-workers or or date at work or heaven
forfend to get married to any of our
coworkers is that where that's going to
end
people that met at the office didn't
start their relationship with some form
of harassment or assault but I totally
see what you're seeing it's the words
that arrest that's a question where's
the line exactly as you will read the
standard of harassment or assault of
course anything like eye contact you're
asking someone obviously the dream could
be considered harassment or assault so
maybe so I think that there might just
need to be some more creative ways in
order for people to start relationships
at work I'm not too worried about that I
am kind of worried about the trend
moving in the direction you talked about
the pendulum swinging about trivializing
matters of flirting that aren't really
earth trivializing sexual assault by
talking about flirting or asking someone
out for a drink or denying someone who
you know wanted to stay over or
something like that I think that we need
to be very clear with our definition of
what sexual assault and sexual
harassment is so we don't trivialize
actual victims and that's the direction
that I see is going in and I think
that's probably what scares me the most
mm-hmm I will say when Marshall flirts
with me every day I don't take that as
harassment maybe some people would call
it harassment I'm actually flattered
compliment
oh yeah it's a nice compliment yeah
there's the harassment I hope HR was
listening to that but yes and one answer
might be gentlemen leanness chivalry
crazy ideas I know but they they are
still out there that's the direction I
know I'm such a bigoted patriarch okay
on that point since I'm the patriarch
get out of here you get out of here all
of you Ally Stuckey Jacob Erie and
Alicia crass thank you for being here as
always that is our entire show today we
have a lot more to talk about but sorry
guys we're out of time and my movement
watch tells me we're at a time so I will
see you all tomorrow
getting your mailbag questions I know we
missed it last week because of
Thanksgiving so make sure that you get
them in and we'll may be doing a little
extended one
I am Michael Knowles as the Michael Nolt
show come back tomorrow we will do it
all again
[Music]
the Michael Noel's show is produced by
Marshall Benson executive producer
Jeremy boring senior producer Jonathan
hey supervising producer
Mathis Glover our technical producer is
Austin Stevens edited by Alex's and Garo
audio is mixed by Mike Cora Mina hair
and makeup is by Jeshua alvera the
Michael nul show is a daily wire for
word publishing production copyright for
word publishing 2017